يحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد عاد تعبير الحرب
البارده ليطل براسه من جديد علينا حيث
البعض ان الصراع الدائره بين الروس
والامريكيين بسبب اوكرانيا هو استعاده
لتلك الحرب القديمه بين الاتحاد السوفيتي
الكاتب حلمي النمل في مقال له بعنوان
الحرب البارده اوهام وكوابيس يرى ان اهم
محور داره حوله الحرب البارده هو الاساس
والفكري
لنا للنظريه الماركسيه السياسيه
مع رفض لاي دور للقطاع الخاص واعتبار رجال
الاعمال
الوصوفه في المقابل فان الولايات المتحده
نظريتها السياسيه مضاده تماما وتقوم على
الفكر ليبراليه الذي يسمح بتعدد الاحزاب
وحريه الاراء والمعتقدات والافكار اما
اقتصاديا فتتبنى الراسماليه وحريه السوق
كما يستبعد طب الحرب البارده في اللحظه
الحاضره قائلا ان استعاده الحرب البارده
وهم وقد تكون كابوسا معللا بانه ليس لدى
روسيا ولا الرئيس بوتين نظريه امميه يبشر
بها ويتبناها بوتين يتبنى القوميه الروسيه
كما ان الصين كطرف ثالث ليست عندها نظريه
تريد طرحها او فرضها على اصدقائها
وبالتالي فانما يسمى بالحرب البارده اصبح
شيئا من الماضي وغير قابل للتكرار في
عصرنا الحالي
نناقش هذا الموضوع
ونستضيف كاتب هذا المقال نفهم معه اكثر
لماذا تطرق لهذه الفكره في هذا التوقيت
بالتحديد من القاهره الدكتور حلمي نمنا مع
الكاتب السياسي اهلا بك دكتور ومن باريس
دكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس اهلا بكما
واسمحالي ان ابدا من القاهره معك يا دكتور
حلمي حضرتك كتبت هذا المقال فرحت فكره
الحرب البارده واستبعت ولو انك في البدايه
بدات بتسلسل احداث طرحت فكره ان تكون هناك
افكار مستبعده ولكنها فيما بعد تصبح
وكانها امنيات
تاليها تسريبات لها اخبار مؤكده ولكنك
تراجعت في النهايه وقلت بانه مهما تكون
امنياتنا او احلامنا الا ان حربا بارده هي
مستحيله في هذا الوقت ولكن سؤالي لماذا
اخترت الحديث عن همم هذا الموضوع بالتحديد
في هذه المرحله
لانه انا ملاحظ انه في الفتره الاخيره
في التحليلات السياسيه في داخل مصر وفي
العالم العربي في عدد من الصحف بعض
المقالات بالاضافه الى عدد من القنوات
الفضائيه المصريه وغيرها وحتى بعض
الشخصيات العامه كسر الحديث في مصر بالذات
عن اننا تقريبا بقينا في الحرب البارده
دخلنا حرب بارده جديده وان علينا ان نحدد
موقفنا من الان وانه همم نذكر حينما عقدت
القمه العربيه الصينيه في الرياض بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وشاركت مصر فيها شاركت فيها الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي ثم بعد ذلك القمه الافريقيه
الامريكيه وشاركت مصر فيها طرح سؤال كبير
في مصر في الراي العام للرئاسه المصريه
نحن مع من مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ام مع الصين ام مع روسيا
واخذ الحديث شكل الامنيات ان احنا
في ضجر من الدور الامريكي في المنطقه فان
احنا بدانا نتصور ان الحرب البارده
عادت بالفعل وان علينا ان نحدد موقفنا من
الان مع الصين ومع روسيا والبعض تشجع بعض
وتغيرات الجنسيه
مستبعده جدا
ما رايك هل نحن نعيش بدايات حرب بارده هل
هناك همم دلائل على اقترابها او على
حضورها على الاقل
لا لا اعتقد اننا امام حرب بارده ك تلك
التي يعرفها العالم بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه التي كانت بين معسكريين كبيرين
همم معسكر بقياده الولايات المتحده همم
ومعسكر بقياده الاتحاد السوفيتي روسيا
الان كما الصين
تعتمدان النظام الراسمالي الذي كان قائما
ومازال قائما في الغرب لكن تعتمدنه من دون
دوله قانون ودوله حق همم ضمن سلطه في
الحاله الصينيه همم ما زال الديكتاتوريه
وفي الحاله الروسيه تسلطيه همم في المقابل
الدول الغربيه لم تعد معسكر واحدا معنيا
بنفس المواجهات كما كان الامر في مرحله
معينه همم لا يوجد الان بالتالي تباينات
اديولوجيه او فكريه انما هناك بايونات في
المصالح ونحن امام عالم تعات تشكيل
التحالفات فيه
اا ليس لي همم حرب بارده جديده ستدور
وانما ربما لاعاده تعريف ما هي ثنائيه
القطبيه او ثلاثيه القطبيه او حتى رباعيه
القطبيه بعد ان ساده لفتره منذ انهيار
جدار برلين وانهيار الاتحاد السوفياتي
سادت هيمنه امريكيه مطلقه او شبه مطلقه
الان همم روسيا تريد ان تقول انها دوله
عظمى وهي لا تملك من مقومات الدوله العظمى
سوى القوه العسكريه التي ايضا بدا لها
حدود الان الصين لا تملك القوه السياسيه
انما تملك القوه الاقتصاديه لتكون دوله
عظمى الولايات المتحده همم تملك اكثر من
همم المقومات الروسيه والصينيه لكن لوحدها
لا تستطيع ايضا ان تفرض هيمنتها كما في
مرحله سابقه واوروبا تحاول في ظل كل هذا
التنافس الدولي ان تدرس كتب جديد لكن دون
ذلك صعوبات بعضها عسكري بعضها يرتبط
بالخلافات بين لندن وباريس وبيرلين
والتنافس فيما بينها وهناك ايضا دول صاعده
اقتصاديه وربما سياسيا لكن لا تستطيع ان
تلعب ادوارا تتخطى بكثير مداها الجغرافي
اعني البرازيل والهند ولديها ايضا صعوبات
داخليه لذلك نحن امام خريطه عالميه يعد
تشكيله التحالفات فيها وقد لا تبقى احاديه
القطبيه لكنها لم تكون في حرب بارده همم
دكتور حلمي همم لماذا او ما هي الملامه
التي ملامح الحرب البارده المفقوده في هذا
همم في هذه المرحله والتي على اثرها
ان تكون في بدايه حرب رداء او قد تكون على
ابوابنا ربما
الحقيقه معظم مقاومات الحرب البارده التي
انتهت بسقوط حائط برلين ليست موجوده
الاساس الفكري والايديولوجي ليس ليس قائما
بمعنى كانت هناك الغرب بزعامه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بيتبنى نظريه معينه
الاتحاد السوفيتي كان متبنيا النظريه
المركسيه هذا لم يعد قائما الان تقريبا
الراسماليه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه هي
لسائده في العالم كله دلوقتي يعني اا
الصين متبنيه بنموذج الراسمالي في الانتاج
في التوزيع في كل الاشياء اقتصاديا لكن
سياسيا لا ايضا همم الاتحاد السوفيتي في
روسيا بتحاول ان تفعل الشئ نفسه روسيا
فعلا كما قال الدكتور ماجد همم ليس لديها
الان من ملامح القوه العظمى سوى الترسانه
النوويه الضخمه التي لديها وهي اللي
مساعداها وموقفاها على رجلها لكن
الاقتصاديه لديها مشاكل كثيره صناعيا ده
مشاكل كثيره 2 روسيا الان وحدها روسيا من
قبل كانت الاتحاد السوفيتي كان معها
اوروبا الشرقيه بالكامل كان مراها تكتل
ضخم جدا يعتمر بامرها وتهايمن وتسيطر على
كل شيء في الان ده ليس قائما وليس مرشحا
للعوده باي شكل من الاشكال يعني فكره انه
تبقى في كتله تسيطر على 12 او 13 دوله الى
جوارها توسيطر عليها عسكريا وسياسيا الى
درجه ان هي اللي تختار مين مسك كثير عامل
حزب مين رئيس المخابرات مين قائد الجيش ده
ليس موجوده وليس مرشحا لانه يتواجد
وبالتالي الحديث عن العالم نفسه ايضا
المزاج العالم يتغير العالم بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه شيء ونحن الان في مرحله
تماما لا يوجد اساس النظري
دكتور حلمي يطرح البعض فكره ان تكون هناك
حرب بارده همم ولكن بشكل جديد حضرتك تحدثت
عن الفكر تحدث عن الايديولوجيا الغير
موجوده تحدثت عن همم بعض العوامل او بعض
الملامح المفقوده في الفتره الحاليه
لنقول بانه هناك حرب بارده ولكن بعض يصلي
تضهو على العقوبات اليوم هناك دول كبرى
الصين روسيا هناك دول تضغط عليها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم باستخدام عقوبات قد
تكون قاسيه هل هذا يمكن ان يكون شكل جديد
من الحرب لا نعلم ان كنا سنويه بارده او
غير بارده ولكن هل هو شكل جديد من الحروب
نعيشه في هذه المرحله
هذا اللي حضرتك تحدثت عنه هو شكل من اشكال
الهيمنه الامريكيه على كثير من دول العالم
وده اللي حصل دقيق وضجر منه وبالذات في
منطقتنا العربيه احنا في منطقتنا العربيه
منذ الاحتلال الامريكي للعراق في 2003 ثم
ما جاء بعد ذلك الحقيقه ان ده عمل حاله من
من الضجيج والدجر والملل من الهيمنه
الامريكيه مع اا ما يحدث في اسرائيل وتاخر
اعلان قيام الدوله الفلسطينيه واشياء
كثيره جدا ادت الى هذا الملل وهذا الضجر
وده اللي بيخلينا امنياتنا وامالنا بتذهب
الى ان احنا نستعيد الماضي مره اخرى ويبقى
زي ثنائيه همم
ايظن هاور وبالجنين في العدوان الثلاثي
هذا نموذج غير قابل للتكرار التاريخ لا
يعيد نفسه ولا يكرر نفسه الانسانيه دائما
لديها الجديد وانا باتصور ان احنا نحن
الان في حاله من القلق ومن الاضطراب
العالم بيعاد تشكيله لكن حتى هذه اللحظه
ما تزال الهيمنه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه صحيح لم تعد هي القطب الاوحد
ولا هي القطب المطلق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان لا تستطيع ان تكون تحالف
مثل الذي كونته سنه 2003 ضد الرئيس
العراقي الراحل صدام حسين ولا تستطيع ان
تبني تحالف مثل الذي بناته سنه بعد عقب 11
سبتمبر في افغانستان لا يمكن انها تبني ده
لانه حتى في وقتها خلينا نفتكر لما فرنسا
في زمن الرئيس جاك شيراك ودوفيل بان لما
كان رئيس وزراء حاولوا ان يخرجوا عن هذه
الهمه حتى في المعسكر الغربي نفسه داخل
اوروبا اظن انه
لم يعودوا متقبلين بشكل جيد
الان حينما تتجه المانيا الى انها ترفع
موازنتها العسكريه وتتجه اليابان الى ان
ترفع موازنه العسكريه هذا يعني ان القوه
الالمانيه تريد ان تظهر وان تقلل من
اعتمادها حتى الاعتماد العسكري على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن باذاء
عالم قد يكون متعدد الاقطاب ومتعدد الدول
لكن فكره قطب واحد او قطبين اظن هذه مرحله
انتهت
كذلك يحمل انتقادات لهذه الفكره ونقشنا
ذلك همم قبل همم حلقات في بانوراما لبعض
يقول بانه الهيمنه او همم النظام العالمي
سيبقى في يد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
موضوع ربما سنقشه لاحقا ولكن اكثر معك يا
دكتور زياد همم خرجنا من الاطار التقليدي
في توصيف او في تعريف الحرب البارده ما
نعيشه اليوم من صراع الضيف يطلق عليه
الهيمنه المستمره للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حضرتك هل توافقه في هذه التسميه
قد تصنف هذه الصراعات بطريقه اخرى
اعتقد ان واشنطن الان لم تعد همم يعني
القطب الذي يستطيع ان يملي شروطه على
الكثير من دول العالم لاسباب عديده ترتبط
بتبدل المدى الاستراتيجي لبعض الدول ترتبط
بالاستهلاك الاقتصادي بالعلاقات مع الصين
ترتبط بمنظومات اقليميه تحاول ان ترسخ
نفسها ان في امريكا الجنوبيه او في
افريقيا او في اسيا او في اوروبا طبعا لكن
كل هذا لا يعني ان القدره تاثير الامريكيه
هي في صدد التراجع الجذري ما زالت هناك
قدره امريكيه من خلال همم الاعلام من خلال
العلاقات السياسيه من خلال موازنات الضخمه
من خلال تطور التكنولوجيا والاستهلاك
التكنولوجيا الذي ترتبط به معظم الشعوب
همم الكمبيوتر والانترنت والتكنولوجيا
حديثه التي لم يعد للعيش من دونها امكانيه
في الكثير من الاماكن معظمها ياتي من
الولايات المتحده وهذا يديم شكل من اشكال
الهيمنه قد نسميه تقنيه او ثقافيه ترتبط
ايضا بالموسيقى بالافلام بهوليود ترتبط
بانماط عيش
بماكل اصبحت الاكثر انتشارا وكل هذا لا
يوجد في عالم اليوم دوله اخرى تستطيع ان
تنافس امريكا في ذلك لكن التسلط السياسي
الذي اعتمدته امريكا لفتره طويله وقدرتها
على حشد التحالفات كما اشار الضيف من
القاهره او قدرتها على فرد تحالفات واسعه
جدا للتحضير لحروب هذا تراجع وهمم الان
تستطيع ان تفرض عقوبات بالطباع واوروبا
ايضا تفرض عقوبات همم ومن يعتدي عسكريه في
المرحله الراهنه هو روسيا والردود الغربيه
على ذلك ترتبط ترتبط عفوا بابقاء
القوى كما هي وعدم السماح لها بالذهاب همم
بعيدا في عدوانها الاوروبي اما الصين
فشقنا اخر اعتقد يرتبط اكثر بالتنافس
الاقتصادي منه باي شيء اخر
وهناك تقديرات اننا في العام 2030 قد نشهد
تبدل همم مهم في احجام التبادل الاقتصادي
بين الكثير من دول العالم والصين من جهه
ونفس الدول وامريكا قد يكون هذا التبادل
فيه لصالح الصين همم لكن لا يبدل مره
جديده من موازين القوى العامه حيث الثقافه
والاستهلاك والسياسه والدبلوماسيه
والموازنات ضخمه ما زالت لصالح واشنطن او
لصالح امريكا
الشكر على المشاركه وكل ما تفضلت ما به من
قراءات من القاهره حلم النمنم الكاتب
السياسي وامباريسه دكتور زياد ماجد استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في
باريس شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]